good evening
good evening and thank you so much for
coming
i'm dr debbie budd president here at
berkeley city college
and we are thrilled that you are joining
us this evening
for what i would like to call our
seventh in the series
of our msri simon's institute
berkeley city college partnership
i would like to before i introduce uh dr
richard carp who will introduce our
speaker
tell you just a little bit about
berkeley city college because i
absolutely know i see some new faces
in this room a show of hands how many of
you are here for the first time at
berkeley city college
wow that's exciting thank you
well thank you to our wonderful speaker
who's helped bring everyone out
berkeley city college is one of the four
colleges in the peralta community
college district
and we are one of the 112 community
colleges
in the state we offer two year degrees
associate degrees for transfer we offer
career technical education programs
and we help students with their
foundational skills
many of you may not know that anyone can
attend a community college
think anyone who's 18 years of old 18
years of age
whether they've attended completed high
school or not could come to community
college
get their associate's degree and
transfer to a four-year university
so we offer an incredible opportunity
for many students
with the cost of education we have more
and more students now coming to berkeley
city college as their first choice
for their first two years and we are
thrilled with our success we have with
our students
we are number one in the state in the
acceptance rate to
uc berkeley with our great partnerships
and we are in the top 10 statewide of
all of the ucs which is really exciting
um and we just learned yesterday i know
we have many uh stanford and cal
individuals that actually one of our
students is one of the 12
transfer students being accepted to
harvard this year so we have a huge
variety
of students so we're excited about that
in addition to the incredible transfer
programs
we do a great deal with our career
technical education
we offer incredible programs to help in
the field of
multimedia biotechnology
and various business related fields and
of course
computer information systems and
computer science
we also in addition to transfer to ucs
students that come to berkeley city
college can receive an associate degree
for transfer
it's an automatic transfer degree to a
cal state university
so we have over 11 different programs
for aaa degrees
that once students complete that with a
2.0
they get automatic acceptance into a csu
so if this is your first time we have
ambassadors always at berkeley city
college we welcome you
to walk in the door and say hey i'd love
a tour we'd love to give you a tour
before i turn it over to our keynote
speaker
and the sponsor simon's institute i
wanted to give
a very special thank you to
dean antonio barrero who has really
helped with all seven of these series
make it possible so antonio thank you
very much
and of course our sound and light and
media technology person brian gibbs
who's done incredible work for us over
the year thank you very much
so again welcome to berkeley city
college
and without any further ado i would like
to introduce dr
richard carp thank you
thank you very much debbie i'm the
director of an
institute that was founded about two
years ago
called the simons institute for the
theory of computing
among the things we do in particular is
outreach to the public to inform the
public about interesting developments in
mathematical and computational sciences
and our cooperation with berkeley city
college
through debbie and with msri
through david eisenbud and his staff has
been
a great pleasure
this is the third in the series of seven
this is the third one that our institute
has been
particularly involved in just a word
about the simon's institute
we study fundamental problems about
computation
that arise in a diverse set of areas
partly in computer science itself and
information technology
but also some of the problems arise in
mathematics
in the physical sciences the engineering
sciences
the social sciences and even in the
world of commerce so we take a very
broad view
of our field and this is likely to be
reflected in some of the future programs
that we run
for an audience like yourselves
at this very nice venue
we're very happy to have michael sipser
as
our key speaker our main speaker today
uh mike got his phd from berkeley in
1980
in our theoretical computer science
group
he spent the bulk of his career at mit
as a professor of mathematics as chair
of the mathematics department
and most recently as acting dean of
science
for him at mit he's a great expositor
he's written a wonderful book in
theoretical computer science
he's proved wonderful theorems
and i think you're going to enjoy his
talk the title is
beyond computation the p versus np
question
mike
first uh thank you dick for the
introduction and i want to thank
berkeley city college for hosting us
and also the simon's institute for
theoretical computer science
and the mathematical sciences research
institute
for sponsoring this event and most of
all i want to thank you all
for coming out here on this beautiful
berkeley evening
to come here a talk about mathematics
because that's what we're talking about
today is mathematics it's theoretical
computer science it's talk about
computation
and um uh
um and the limits of computation but it
is
also a mathematical talk
and not only am i going to talk about
mathematics but i'm going to tell you
about a problem
that i don't know how to solve
no one else does either for that matter
but maybe that's why you're here because
you know it's those unsolved
problems unsolved questions unanswered
questions the
the um open questions as we like to say
that often are what are most inspiring
to our curiosity
so i'm going to talk about a problem um
at
the crossroads between mathematics and
computer science called the p versus np
problem and um and by the way even
though it's a math talk i'm gonna
hopefully make it accessible to
everybody
uh and if i don't if you don't if you
get lost
well it's my fault um so
i don't feel bad but i i think it'll be
hopefully accessible
all right so the p versus np problem
this is a question about what makes
certain
kinds of problems easy easy to solve
or quickly to solve on a computer and
other kinds of problems
take a long time to solve on a computer
even though the computer
is very fast okay so we're going to
start off slow
the nice easy example um
7 times 13. so this is something we call
multiplica multiplication and uh
if your arithmetical skills are rusty
the answer to that 7 times 13 problem is
91.
okay now um
a related problem to multiplication is
suppose i give you the product
to start off with i give you a number 91
which is say
known to be the product of two numbers
but you don't know what those numbers
are and i ask you
to figure out the two numbers that
multiply together to give you 91.
this is another computational or
mathematical problem
and we call that the factoring problem
we start out with the product and we try
to figure out the two numbers that
multiply together
to give you that product okay so in this
case the problem is 91 and the answer is
7
times 13. okay
now let's take a bigger example
of multiplication
so this is probably not the kind of
problem that you can do in your head
at least if you're a normal person but
you can type this into a computer
and even a laptop
push the um if you have the right
software
push multiply and the answer will pop
out
almost instantaneously so this
multiplication problem even though it's
for big numbers will take
very you know because computers are so
fast even using the standard algorithm
that you learn in third grade for
multiplying
it can run through the calculation very
quickly and get you the answer in a
second
or even less now
here is where it becomes interesting
suppose i take that product
and i forgot the two numbers that
multiply together
to give you that product and now i want
to find those two numbers just like we
did before this is a factoring
problem okay so here's the product and i
want to know what two numbers multiply
together to give you that number
well you can solve that problem on a
computer
just like we did for multiplication
and somebody actually did that but
here's the difference instead of taking
a second for doing the multiplication
doing this factoring problem took 20
computer years of effort 20 computer
years of computer time
now they didn't actually wait for 20
years
they ran this on a highly parallel
set of computers so they were all a
bunch of computers working together on
this problem
but if you add up the total amount of
computer effort that was involved
it was 20 computer years years of effort
to do this factoring now
first of all you might ask well you know
well who cares you know why did somebody
invest so much time to do this factoring
well
people do care and in particular the
person who did
this uh exercise of factoring that
number
got twenty thousand dollars for doing
that calculation
that's not bad uh
now you may ask well first of all who's
paying
twenty thousand dollars to factor big
numbers and
you know are there any other numbers out
there that people might want to factor
that you know
we can also get in on this act well you
know let's take
this number here this is a 30 000 number
okay no one knows the factors of this
one
now um so so who
but who's paying um well first of all
i'm lying
uh the people who are paying
uh decided to get out of that game so
we missed out our opportunity that's no
longer the the the
the um payment for factoring big numbers
has not that's been discontinued
so but still people are interested and
mathematicians
are very work very hard on understanding
how to factor big numbers so
but still who was paying well there's a
company called
rsa security and they're involved with
cryptography
sending encrypted messages on the
internet
you know your bank transactions for
example in
such a way that no one else can
see what the transaction is or interfere
with it
so there are cryptographic codes
that rely on their security
uh for uh that rely
for their security on the difficulty on
the presumed
difficulty of factoring big numbers if
you were to be able to factor
things quickly then you would
break that code so
the people who created this code and
created that company are very
interested to know where the people find
fast ways of factoring numbers
and so i think to keep their kind of
finger
on the pulse of what's going on out
there in the factory
technology world they were offering
these prizes
now they've gotten out of that business
um
but still factoring is an important
ingredient in modern day cryptography
and that's where
at least the practical interest in
factoring
or algorithms for factoring comes from
though mathematicians have been
interested in factoring for centuries
okay so what is so hard about factoring
what makes it different for multiplying
well you know when you're multiplying
two numbers you can in a sense
construct the answer out of the problem
there is a procedure which constructs
the answer
but when you're factoring uh a number
you want to find those two numbers that
multiply together
the only way that people know how to
solve that problem
is essentially to search for the factors
no one has a procedure essentially you
know there are little things that you
can do but essentially
no one knows how to factor numbers kind
of by constructing the factors
the only way that people know how to do
it is by looking for the factors
and when you have a big number the
number of possibilities you would have
to search through
in order to find the factors might be
astronomically big
there are more possibilities than there
are seconds
in the lifetime of the universe or atoms
you know
in the galaxy so they were talking about
such huge numbers
that when you're trying to search
through a space that that
that's so long it's going to take you a
very very long time
because there are so many possible
factors so
the question that we're interested in
today is
whether there is some other way
to factor numbers that avoids that brute
force search
through many possibilities maybe there's
another procedure for factoring
that is more direct that constructs the
answer instead of looking for the answer
that's the essential question of today
is searching necessary when you're
factoring or
we'll see this comes up in many other
problems as well or
is there some way to avoid searching in
these kinds of problems
the answer to that question is at
present unknown
whether searching is necessary for
certain kinds of problems like factoring
okay let me give you another example
it's called the clique problem
so here you're given a bunch of nodes
we call them they might represent people
say and the lines or edges between the
nodes might represent the relationships
between the people so
you would say you put a line between two
nodes representing people if these two
people know each other
and now you want to have like go out for
dinner you want to get a group of people
together all of whom know each other
and here is your collection of friends
let's say and you want to look in there
for some group let's say of three people
who know each other
because you want to go out to dinner so
here is a group this
this group here these three are a what's
called a clique
these are people who all know each other
they're all connected by these edges
but these three here are not a clique
because this this pair here they don't
know each other
so for the purposes of constructing your
dinner party you're not going to invite
them
let's say so as a mathematical question
we abstract that into just this
mathematical structure here this graph
and we're trying to find
these cliques so here's a three-click a
four-click you know these are all
nodes that are all connected to one
another and you're given your collection
of nodes your friends say whatever
you want to see how big a clique you can
find
because you want to you know make the
biggest dinner party you can
let's say um so you know it's easy to
see there is we already saw that there
were three nodes all connected to
each other there are four uh somewhere
in here
i i know that's true uh like uh
these four here it's like kite shape
thing these are
all four are connected how about five
well not so obvious and turns out there
are five that are connected to each
other these five
if you uh i don't know if you can see
that maybe this will help you out um
so there are there is a five click in
this uh
graph and in general we want to know
you know can we find a clique of a
certain size or what's the biggest
clique in a graph
so you know if you have a bigger set of
friends
um that becomes a more challenging
problem to answer
and you can certainly do it
by going through all the possible
collections if you want to say well i
want to get together eight friends
now to go out for dinner but they all
have to know each other you're gonna
have to go through
lots and lots and lots of possibilities
in order to see if you can find
your those collection of friends which
um
you know all know each other
at least as far as we know maybe there's
some other way
to solve this problem that doesn't
involve going through all the
possibilities
and if you have hundreds and hundreds of
friends trying to find the biggest group
that all know each other the biggest
clique here
might take centuries of computer time
because there are so many possibilities
to go through
okay and again we ask can you
solve this problem in some other way
that doesn't involve searching through
all of those possibilities
we don't know this is an unsolved
question
in mathematics and theoretical computer
science
okay and this is the essence of what we
call the p
versus np problem um
these are both examples of what i would
call let me say
talk about this first of a needle in the
haystack problem
okay so um
i've actually you know given this talk a
couple of times and you know there are
sometimes a lot of
uh people from other countries and they
don't know what hay
is so here this is this is you know hey
this is stuff we feed to
you know uh farm animals and you know
there is this
needle in a haystack probably means
you're trying to look for a needle
somewhere in that stack of hay which
looks like a hard problem um so
um you know because
finding the needle might involve
searching through lots and lots of
possibilities you have to look at that
piece of hay by piece of hay
one by one seeing if you can find that
needle so that's another example of a
searching problem
in a kind of a practical case not a
mathematical case
now kind of abstracting it slightly
here's another picture of a haystack
and you know you want to know whether
finding the needle in your haystack
involves searching or is there some way
to do it without searching
well if you have a magnet
you can just pull that needle out
without having to search for it and
really what we're asking
here is whether
there is in those other problems that i
just described the factoring problem and
the clique problem
is there a mathematical analog of the
magnet
some way which pulls out the the answer
without having to search for it
okay so this phenomenon is pervasive it
exists in hundreds and hundreds of real
world problems that people
really care about this question of
problems that can be solved using
searching
but that's too slow so we'd like to find
a
faster way of solving them that avoids
the search
you know for example you know it's near
the end of the semester
so it's time for final exams
and you'd like to try to find a schedule
for the final exam
so that there aren't too many students
who have to take two final exams at the
same time
that's called a scheduling problem there
are many varieties of scheduling
problems
well if you want to find the schedule
that optimizes minimizes the number of
conflicts you you know you can do that
by searching through all possible
schedules
that's of course astronomically big
and no one really knows if you want to
find the absolute best answer of a way
to do that that's faster than
this brute force search through all
possible schedules so scheduling is an
example of a searching problem
if you want to for example color a map
like you used to do you know my teacher
used to sign those when they didn't
you know when they were in second grade
when the teacher wanted to do something
else they would give these maps and you
have to color them in
um of course two countries that share a
boundary have to be a different color
you want to know given a map what's the
minimum number of crayons you need
to color the map so that you don't have
any
uh countries that border one another
with the same color
um so that problem no one knows how to
solve that problem
um in general even for a map that you
can write down on a surface of
on a piece of paper a planer map to
minimize the number of colors
without searching through all possible
colorings
again so many many colorings out there
um you know essentially there are
sometimes a few shortcuts you can do but
still the only way of solving these
problems
as far as we know involves a search
through a large space of possibilities
um there are problems in computational
biology you want to see if
you're given this you know an amino acid
sequence you want to find the
configuration that it folds into which
minimizes the total energy
um because presumably that's the
uh the configuration that exists inside
the cell well if you want to solve this
problem in general
so that it works for any possible amino
acid sequence
this is another case where finding the
optimal folding
involves searching through essentially
all possible or many many possible
foldings
and there are so many of them um there
are there is theorem proving i'll talk
about that more in a second
uh a variety of puzzles sudoku and so on
uh traveling salesman problem you know
there are hundreds of these maybe
thousands
where problems that you can solve them
by searching but it's very inefficient
it takes very it's very slow and no one
knows if there's a better way
um and that's the that's the essence
of this problem called the p versus np
problem p versus empty question
can we solve these problems which seem
to involve
searching
but without actually resorting to the
search
can we solve these apparently search
problems
in a more direct way than actually
searching
and so
that addresses all of those problems
that we just discussed
clique factoring you know
protein folding and so on it's a
phenomenon is appears in all of them
okay let's just talk for a minute about
this is not essential to understanding
the presentation but let's just try to
define the terms here
p stands for the polynomial time
these are the problems that you can
solve
in a number of steps that grows only as
a polynomial
in the size of the problem
solving a problem by searching for the
answer
will in general require an exponential
number of steps
so these searching procedures
are not polynomial time procedures
so the polynomial time class of problems
are the problems like multiplication
where you can solve them without
searching
but whether for example the clique
problem
is in polynomial time is not known
because if it were then you would be
avoiding the search
for the clique problem so these are the
problems that can essentially be solved
without searching because searching is
too slow to operate in polynomial time
now np is a slightly more complicated
notion
these are problems where
you may not necessarily be able to
find the answer quickly in a polynomial
number of steps in the size of the
problem but you can check the answer
quickly so let's understand what that
means
like in the case of factoring there is
something interesting about factoring
because
even though it might take you a very
long time to find the factors
because of that brute force search once
you've found them
you can easily check that you got the
right answer by just by multiplying them
to see if you get the
the starting point similarly
if your problem your clique problem is
well
does the graph have a clique of size
20 it might take you a long num
many many steps to actually find to run
through all the possibilities
and find such a clique but once you
actually found one it's easy to check
that it works
so there are many many problems that
have this character
um that uh
it seems like you need to search for the
answer but once you
find the answer it's easy to check that
it's right
that's the essence of np these are the
quickly checkable
problems as opposed to the quickly
solvable problems
and they include all the search problems
that we just mentioned
okay so just in terms you know thinking
about in terms of like a venn diagram
uh of classes of problems
so these circles here
represent whole classes of all the of
computational problems like
factoring clique traveling salesmen and
so on
the p problems are the ones that are
easy easily solvable
like multiplication or sorting or any of
those problems where you can do
get the answer quickly whereas np
are the problems where you you may
need uh where the answer once you find
it is easily checkable
but actually finding the answer might
involve searching for it
so these are really the searching
problems out here
and these are the problems that can be
solved without searching
so if it turns out that
searching can that we can always
eliminate searching
then these two classes would collapse
down and be the same
right if if you can always eliminate
searching for these np problem for these
problems that are in np then they would
collapse down and become p
problems solve problems that you can
solve solve quickly
and so then p would equal np in that
case but if there are certain problems
in this class which really require
searching
then they would not be in in p and you
would have p
different from np okay so that's a
little bit on the technical side
but uh that's where this terminology
comes from
the p versus np really amounts to does p
equal np
which means you can always eliminate
searching or p is different from np
which means that sometimes searching is
essential
cannot be eliminated in some cases and
the answer as to which of those cases is
the actual
uh reality is not known
okay that's the p versus np problem so
let's talk a little bit about
of the history of the problem because
it's interesting um
if you go back to the 1960s that was
when the whole subject of complexity
theory got set up
some of these folks are my teachers in
the early
70s the p versus np question was first
formulated
and its companion notion of np
completeness was proposed we'll talk
about that in a second
and uh i'm very pleased that dick
carp who introduced me is was one of the
key uh contributors
uh to this whole development but one
thing that was discovered
i don't know now it's been 15 to 20
years ago is that there was actually a
precursor
to the whole thing that appeared in a
letter
kurt gertle the great logician wrote to
the
uh to the mathematician
john von neumann so there was a letter
which foreshadowed
the whole development and it appeared
back in 1956
almost 10 years before any of this
appeared in the literature which is kind
of amazing
so i thought i would just show you the
letter here here it is in fact
it's a little hard to read not only
because of the the printing is small
but it's in german um
and it was found in von neumann's
archives
uh something around i don't remember
exactly but around 20 years ago
uh i thought i would just translate a
few bits and pieces of it just because
it's interesting to see the language
that was used and
and actually for those of you who know
something about the subject what's
amazing to me anyway about this letter
is the modern terminology
that he uses much before any of this
appeared in the literature
uh oops oh yeah here's the letter let me
i want to tell you first
who who these people are in case you
didn't know kurt gerdel was
many people think of him as the greatest
logician who ever lived or the greatest
logician since aristotle
and he was an amazing person who did all
sorts of stuff in
in mathematical logic and among
his many accomplishments was sort of
this idea
understanding of this question about
computation
which was only known by virtue of that
letter that that
that appeared in von neumann's archives
john von neumann was a great uh
mathematician who worked in a whole
variety of fields
he is known in particular for having
worked in computer science he was an
early computer pioneer
he's known for the so-called von neumann
architecture i don't know if he was
actually the only one to think of that
concept
but this notion that you can uh store
the program of the computer in the
computer itself
so let's turn our attention back to this
letter uh
so the letter starts off in him
translating little bits and pieces of it
the lieber hair von neumann that's
that's the opening here dear mr von
neumann
uh princeton march 20th 1956.
kind of a curious side note is that
both girdle and von neumann
were at the institute for advanced study
at the time
presumably down the hall from one
another
so why exactly their girdle was right
wrote this in a letter to von neumann
item not exactly no
but you can make you know maybe he just
wanted to get it down in print or maybe
uh you know von neumann at the time
actually was rather sick
he was dying of cancer died less than a
year later maybe he just was
not uh maybe he was hospitalized i
actually don't know uh
but in fact the whole beginning part of
the uh the first page of the letter
talks about
how girdle is aware that von neumann is
unwell and he hopes he gets better and
he says at the end of the first thing he
says well
you know now let's turn to some
mathematics
um and here then he talks about
here's really what he's asking here is
you have to explain this
he's talking about the problem of how
hard it is for computers
to test whether
a mathematical statement has a proof
of a certain specified length
okay so you give a length n and i want
to know you're given a length n you give
the statement
and the computer is supposed to check
does that statement has a have a proof
of length
n now if you if you eliminate the n if
you say doesn't mean does the statement
have a proof at all
we know that's not solvable by computer
that was actually derived from some of
griddle's work himself
but if you put the bound on you if you
say does it have a proof of length n
well of course it's now solvable because
you can just try all possible proofs of
length n
and you know and see if any of them are
legitimate proofs of the statement
you're trying to prove
it's a finite problem but
that's a searching solution you have to
search
that procedure involves searching
through all possible proofs of length
and there are so many of them
so what girdle is asking here
is how much time does it take to
test this is his function phi of n
that's how much time
the it would take to solve the problem
for proofs of length n
how how long would it take if you have
an optimal machine
instead of just the brute force
searching machine maybe there's some
better way
so how long does an opt how long would
an optimal machine
take to test if your statement has a
proof of length n
this is the p versus np question
right there formulated in a slightly
different language
but this is really the p versus mp
question you know might quibble slightly
but this is basically it
then he goes on to talk about blossom
probierin which is
i'm told i'm not not a german speaker
but it means
blind probing which i think loosely and
loosely is
brute force search or exhaustive search
that's
searching and then he goes on to talk
about
other problems besides testing whether a
statement has a proof
of a certain length he talks about
testing if a number is prime
or in general other finite combinatorial
problems he doesn't specifically mention
clique but i think that's the kind of
problem he has in mind
so we really hear in this in this letter
he actually has carved out a vision
for where the field ends ended up going
i think it's an amazing discovery in the
history of science
that this letter was found in von
neumann's archives
anyway and then he signs it at the end
kurt curdle
so um in the years
since girdle's letter you know there's
been a lot of
literature and the whole subject has
developed and this
problem now has become celebrated is one
of the great
it's probably the greatest unsolved
problem in theoretical computer science
and it's considered one of the great
problems in contemporary mathematics
so there are these some of you may know
there in the year 2000
there were these clay millennium
problems posed
uh these are supposedly seven unsolved
problems
put together by a committee inspired by
the hilbert problems if you've heard of
those but it doesn't matter
there were a century earlier but these
were put together in the year 2000
kind of as challenges to the
mathematical community for the coming
century
and as you can see the p versus np
problem is considered is was one of
those seven
grand challenge problems in mathematics
one of these problems has a check mark
next to it
because that problem actually was one of
the
seven grandchild challenge problems
that's already been solved
so these are not impossible problems uh
they can be solved that point array
conjecture was 100 years old when it was
solved
and there's a whole story behind it you
know the guy who solved it was a little
bit strange
he uh you know um you know
i should mention one difference between
the clay problems and the
and the um hilbert problems that that
there's a million-dollar bounty
on solving any one of these problems and
the guy who solved the point great
projector didn't want the million
dollars
he said you know what's a million
dollars compared with the glory of
something you put your a conjecture
which i can which i can understand you
know uh this is a problem
you know for the ages and you know how
does that how does a million dollars
compare with that
um so um
so all right let me tell you
now you know i've spent a lot of time
thinking about the p versus np
problem uh people know that it's a
problem i'm interested in
and lots of people send me solutions
um
i get phone calls i get letters and so
on uh
so um and you know many of the solutions
i'm really kind of
simplifying but it's it's actually true
they they
um they kind of some class of
of quote solutions amounts to
essentially
well these problems are searching
problems and of course you need to
search to do searching problems
the end so what i want to show you here
is that it's not so simple
you know testing if a number is prime
looks like a searching problem
right you have a big number you want to
know is it prime does it have any
non-trivia does it have any factors
you know besides one and itself so can
you actually factor that number in some
interesting way
i think most of us know what prime
numbers are
and you want to know you want to test if
a number is prime
so one way to do it is by searching you
can search for
factors and if you don't find any uh
factors then you know it's prime
uh but there's another way
and let me give you a taste of how that
goes it uses some number theory
but not at least at the very most
elementary level it's not
you know it's sort of understandable so
here's a strange way to test primality
and this
it's based on this following principle
that's going to ultimately be used to
avoid the searching
um it relies on this old theorem due to
fermat
it's like you know it's not fermat's
last theorem it's another theorem that
he actually did prove um
uh and it it's the following
simple statement but you have to bear
with me on this is as technical as
as the talk gets okay it's not that bad
um if i have to take a prime p any old
prime
like 7 and i take any number
uh from one up to p minus one so any
number that's less than p
call it a like maybe two
if i take that number a and i raise it
to the p
minus one power
and then i divide by p and take the
remainder
that's what this means mod p divide by p
and take the remainder
i always get one coming out
it's kind of amazing when you actually
try it in practice
why in the world should that be well
from approved it's not actually that
hard to prove
but let's just illustrate this with an
example
okay so let's take the case i mentioned
p equals seven
a equals two
okay so you take two to the sixth power
that's a to the p minus one two to the
sixth power
that's 64. okay
now divide by 7 well 7 goes into
63 evenly so the remainder when you
divide it into 64
is going to be 1. of course this is just
this is no proof this is just an example
but it always works
now contrast that with what happens if
you started with p
equal to 15 which is well known for not
being a prime number
uh okay so p
is we start with 15 a non-prime let's
try plugging in the same thing see what
happens
well you you take a equal to 2 again
now you get 15 minus 1 p minus 1 is 2 to
the 14th
that's this number here and if you take
the if you divide by
15 you get a remainder of four
and four is not one
that tells you something
it tells you that 15 is not prime
because this calculation resulted in a
number
other than one here it resulted in four
i have just proven to you that 15 is not
a prime number
of cause we knew that right but it
proves it in an
entirely different way it proves it says
that 15
is not prime because it fails to have a
property that all prime numbers have
and so therefore it couldn't be prime it
doesn't say anything about 15's factors
by the way
and this is kind of the basic the
starting point for a procedure
that allows you to test primality first
there was a procedure that worked
kind of with a randomized uh and then
ultimately the randomization was
removed and so primality testing is now
known to be solvable
in polynomial time so you can cut out
the searching entirely
using um using this
this is this idea is the starting point
okay so i mentioned this notion of np
completeness
okay um so np completeness is probably
well perhaps it was a very
important early development in trying to
understand this whole phenomenon
of p versus np and what it tells you is
this that
you know we have all of these searching
problems
like factoring clique and a variety of
others
but it turns out that in many cases
the question of whether or not these
problems
require searching is related to each
other
so let me say that slightly better
what we can show by virtue of this np
completeness method
is that if i can find a procedure
which solves the clique problem without
searching
so a polynomial time algorithm for the
clique problem
if i can do that so if i can get rid of
searching for clique then i can get rid
of searching for factoring
you understand this is kind of a miracle
you know what does factoring and clique
have to do with each other
but by eliminating searching from the
solution to the clique problem i
immediately get a way of
eliminating searching for the factoring
problem so how in the world
does that what how do you prove that
because this is this is known
it's because there is a way that you can
demonstrate
and this is very concretely done too
complicated for me to say here but
at least the idea i can say you you can
convert
factoring problems into into clique
problems
by transformation that itself is fast so
in other words i can kind of hide
a factoring problem as a clique problem
i can encode it as a clique problem so
now if i can then solve clique problems
without searching i've i've solved my
factoring problem because i
represented my factoring problem as a
clique problem so i kind of illustrate
that here
okay so that's the idea i can convert a
factoring problem into a cleat problem
and then solve the clique problem that's
that's the essence of np completeness
and well i mean one more point is that
clique is a special problem because
every
np problem every one of these problems
that has easy checkability
as we mentioned at the beginning can be
transformed
by some trans fast transformer into a
clique problem
so we call that we say that clique is np
complete
so in other words if you can solve the
clique problem
fast you can solve every np problem fast
so clique is special and many of these
many problems in np are known to be
special in that way those are called np
complete
um and therefore if you can solve
clique in p then every np problem
can be solved in p you can always
eliminate searching for these easily
checkable problems
so you've kind of focused the entire
complexity of this class of np problems
onto a single problem the clique problem
or any one of the other np complete
problems
okay so now um
okay so this is kind of gives the i
sense these np these np complete
problems are in a sense the hardest
because if you can solve any one of
these you've solved them all
okay now i thought i'd mention too just
you know sort of in getting a little bit
into the home stretch of what i'm
of my lecture that
you know the world is a complicated
place
there are certain kinds of search
problems which seem to be
transcend even np these are searching
problems where
once you find the answer you don't
necessarily have
as far as we know an easy way of
checking the answer
and i'll give you just to illustrate
that it's the problem of
testing which side has the winning
has a forced win in a game like chess
or any of a variety of games if
you um and you have to gen for the
experts on there you have to talk about
generalizations here but let's just be
loose
uh for in a game like chess
um the uh
you know if i want to know what's the
outcome
if both sides play optimally does white
win
does black win or is it or is it always
a draw
under under optimal play if both sides
were
the best possible players no one knows
the answer to that
but you could find it out using a
computer that would search
the entire tree of possibilities so
there is a kind of a searching
procedure because the the tree is
astronomically big you'll never be able
to do it
in the lifetime of the universe but in
principle you can get the answer
and suppose you determine by searching
this tree that white
does in fact have a forced wind how do
you check that no
that's not something we know how to do
so this is a problem which is a
searching problem which seems even
outside of the np class
it's a searching problem that doesn't
have this easy check ability as far as
we know
and this is one of these you know this
well as far as we know
um okay so just to give you a sense of
the lay of the land you know in the many
years that complexity theorists have
been looking at these kinds of things
you know they've placed these problems
here optimal games is in a
is in a class called not called
polynomial space these can be solved
with a polynomial amount of memory
not necessarily a polynomial amount of
time here are the clique and factoring
problems
in this np class as we saw is
multiplication
down in the p class but complexity
theorists have
been hard at work trying to come up with
other methods of categorizing problems
in a natural way almost like the
periodic table in
some loose sense so there's a variety of
different classes out there that people
have discovered
corresponding to classifying problems in
different ways
and the whole subject is still
evolving so if you focus here on for
example the primality
problem it used to be
up here in this rp class which stands
for randomized
polynomial time but about
you know dozen years ago a procedure for
eliminating the randomization was shown
so it's
fairly recently you know the this
picture has
has changed and you know it's
other changes are possible so
you know so we have this unsolved
problem p
versus np how might we actually answer
it of course i don't know
um but uh we can speculate you know one
possible method that
is suggests itself would be you know you
want to
show that there's no clever way to solve
a problem
like the clique problem you have to
search
if you want to prove p is different from
np which is what most people believe
not necessarily everybody but most
people believe p different femininity
that
these problems really require searching
um
then you uh for you
a fast algorithm is kind of your
adversary
you want to prove that there's no fast
algorithm
for the clique problem because you
believe searching is necessary
so the fast procedures are kind of the
bad guys you don't like the fast
procedures you want to show there aren't
any of those
so this is the fast procedure which is
claiming to solve the clique problem but
the problem is that fast procedure can
be very clever can do crazy things like
that
procedure for testing primality all
sorts of things who knows what it could
do
so one way perhaps is to get a handle on
it
by limiting the class of procedures that
you'll allow
you handicap the computer
so you take it with a stick you hit that
computer and so now the computer instead
of being able to run it can only kind of
limp
and maybe now you can prove the computer
has to take a long time to solve the
problem because it's limping if that
doesn't work you give it another whack
now for a computer can only crawl
eventually enough wax
you can prove something and then maybe
you can
start to relax some of these handicaps
that you put on the computation
and you learn something about what it
takes to show that there are no
clever algorithms um
all right another possibility would be
you want to take your
algorithm which supposedly is working
fast for the clique problem
and you want to somehow find a very
complicated input
and say on this input it's going to have
to take a long time
um well uh
you know if you want to find a
complicated case it's sort of natural to
work with a very big instance
the bigger the problem sort of the more
complicated it is and to a mathematician
that sort of suggests why don't we take
that to its most extreme
let's try to give it an infinite input
whatever that means
okay try to make sense of that and to
show that maybe on this infinite input
it's easier
somehow to say that the machine has to
take out
a long time again you're not clear what
these means but you can make
some sense of these things um okay but
you know
all the none of these approaches have
panned out in the end
unfortunately um and so
you know you can ask well will the
problem ever be solved
i believe it will but we'll certainly
need new
ideas to do so thank you